i'm in florida and it's hot and for a
lot of us stuck at home we're getting
a little antsy a little bored so that's
why i decided to test the age-old adage
it's hot enough to fry an egg on the
sidewalk with my own
sidewalk the temperature right now is in
the upper 90s the feel like is 10
degrees above that
i think it should be pretty easy let's
find out
oh crap well it's got some shells in
that all right let's let her rip i'm
sweating so much it is so hot
out here i can't believe this isn't
cooking is this the hottest cyborg
probably not
gonna cook on any of the sidewalks you
don't think it's gonna cook at all
turns out it's not as easy as i thought
i did miserably i think it's time to
pull out the big guns
i'm reaching out to the world's foremost
egg frying on the sidewalk expert
fredeck my name is fredek
i was the producer of the open egg
frying for the last 30 years
so how did the oatman egg frying contest
start
that that came to be about because we
were the hottest spot in the nation
we're right in the desert we're right in
the tri-state area of california nevada
and arizona right on the colorado river
they said we got to do something
for the summertime because we're always
talking about having nothing to do in
the summer because it's too hot
and if it's that hot yeah make it fun to
be outside
yeah i said well why don't we have an
egg fry on the sidewalk and see what
that could do
bring a lot of people and i started the
whole thing off so on july the 4th
uh 1993 we had an a fry well we first
put the egg onto the sidewalk to see if
we could fry it on the sidewalk
you threw it on the sidewalk and it just
didn't work they
just sat there and it didn't do anything
it didn't work for me either
we couldn't fry any eggs on the sidewalk
in 15 minutes because the temperature
would have to be 160 degrees
well you'd be frying yourself with rosie
eggs so we couldn't do that the main
thing is
is to have a device that's going to make
that egg fry like a frying pan or
something like that
and it's got to be hot and if it's not
hot it's not going to work describe to
me the perfect sidewalk egg what does it
look like well the outside of the the
egg of course is kind of a gel
and it's transparent when that turns
white your egg is fried
are there any really weird methods
people use to fry eggs on the sidewalk
like something i wouldn't have thought
of people have come up with devices
where they cooked them with frying pans
so they used aluminum foil
magnifying glasses and glasses and all
kinds of stuff it's a trombone
and it's upside down ring would draw the
heat to the egg and shoot it up to the
egg
i see another one where it looks like
somebody had foil in a jar
that was a device where the jar was
amplified to heat
it was very unique and different the
device one time that was really good it
was a solar mirror
he cooked the eggs in three minutes and
it was fried to a crisp so you can't do
it
you could actually make a full breakfast
if you have the right kind of device
absolutely they were cooking eggs and
bacon and hash browns
and i couldn't believe that but i saw
and they did it so an important part of
egg frying is
the showmanship you have to fry it with
style right
they get all dressed up in different
costumes and that was one of the fun
that dressed up as the devil
as a welder anything to draw attention
to the fact that we're trying ace on the
sidewalk
yes so you're in arizona it's hot i'm in
florida
it's really hot but it's not 115 degrees
is that hot enough to fry an egg uh i
know you can do it
papasan up there he'll he'll take care
of you and he'll fry your egg real good
just come up with something and it'll
work
[Music]
so i don't have solar mirrors but
i do have regular mirrors i think i can
rig up a few of these devices that
people have used to fry eggs at this
contest and hopefully one of them works
all right
egg you got it okay so it's hot
in florida but it's not death valley hot
so i'm already at a disadvantage so i'm
going to need all the devices i can find
to try to get eggs
hot enough so that they can actually fry
with this pan
i'm going to try uh with a magnifying
glass i'm just going to
set it up like this let's try this other
weirdest method
in a glass container you gotta get it in
foil
you gotta get it in there um i think i
gotta get like a mirror out here too
so i'm gonna just put that light right
on the egg
just egg in a foil now it's really
hot 122 degrees 15 minutes and counting
so this one's got the mirror this one's
got the magnifying glass
this one's this weird contraption and
this is pretty just basic so we're going
to be able to compare
these four eggs one of them better cook
that's all i got to say this one already
looks pretty
good didn't have a devil costume but had
the dog head so now i'm hot dog and i'm
working on some hot eggs
oh my god this is actually like way too
hot i don't think i can do this
oh god how's everything going
oh my god they're not in here needing to
turn it is so hot at
and these eggs are not cooking
[Applause]
i'm using the devices i wish i had
something solar powered like fred
suggested but i don't
so i'm just trying my best
i'll never make bacon so still hours
have passed
and the eggs are not quite getting there
so i really gotta step it up so now i'm
gonna fry an egg
and i'm going to apply everything to
this one egg
i'm putting all my eggs in one basket so
to speak
so this is what i'm doing i'm going to
be preheating the
pan on the hood of this car because it's
much hotter on the hood of that car
so get it nice and hot i'm going to be
using the magnifying glass
i'm going to be using the mirror and
hopefully
i'm gonna finally fry an egg on this hot
ass sidewalk
oh my god oh my god wait i think it's
working
oh my god wait a second
i can't believe how well this is working
oh my god all right
we gotta add bacon oh my god
you hear that sizzle oh my god i'm gonna
be able to do a whole breakfast
it's a good-looking egg i mean i
actually probably like it
honestly i think i overcooked the egg
honestly preheating the cast iron
on the car was key for this to be
successful
hey who knows maybe next year if the
pandemic's gone i'll travel to arizona
and enter that
egg frying competition myself because i
think i think i got it now
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you